run small
pro-ice um we can move up this place too
little and there
many years ago when I was the wife of a
brand-new Texas congressman I snapped
photographs outside these iron gates I
never imagined that one day I would live
on the other side of that fence like
many tourists I had the distinct feeling
that this house belonged in part to me I
think that's a feeling that everyone who
visits here shares just like the
thousands who come here each year I was
impressed by the majesty of the great
state rooms on the first floor and was
proud of the stream of history that ran
through each of them what the passerby
doesn't always realize is that there are
two sides to the White House the
official side that remains in the public
eye and the private side that the public
rarely sees the living quarters for the
president and his family
this is our living room actually it's
the west end of the long hall it's the
nerve center and crossroads of all
family activities an intimate place and
yet busy and it belongs to all the
family psychologically when you cross
that threshold you feel that you're at
home that you're inside your own house
you can put on a robe and slippers and
curl up with a good book we gather here
on all the climactic occasions such as
the immediate moments following the
State of the Union message are another
major address to the nation we usually
invite those who worked on the speech or
who had contributed to the event on
those nights this room has been filled
it has the same electric quality of a
Broadway opening after the performance
you're anxious to hear the reviews
although we've had some thrilling
successes and high moments of pride
there with some chilly moments too but
happy are painful this is where the
initial public reaction is seen by the
president and this is where his family
shares this experience this room is also
a listening post for the tone of the day
when we have no engagements in the
evening I come in here with some of my
work that isn't so demanding and wait
for Linden to come home from his work
you can see his office from here the
lights may be on until 8 o'clock or
maybe 9 o'clock or 10 o'clock sometimes
he doesn't come home to dinner until
after midnight it's not very far for a
man to commute but in terms of his
responsibilities there is a great
distance from here to there I recall
being up here as Linda browning in her
latest acquisition for old book
collection and Lucy emerged from the
kitchen with a pan of brownies she'd
made
at the same time knowing that Lyndon was
down there only a few yards away but the
tensest mites of all of the lights on in
the Cabinet Room and the television vans
on Executive Avenue perhaps it was the
crisis of a gulf of tonkin
of the Middle East in June 67 but sooner
or later the lights will go out and then
in a few moments our here at eager boys
down the hall call out where's byrd and
then i know he's home really home like
the living room in any american home
this room has its personal touches
bookshelves that reflect the individual
interests of a family old and treasured
friends one of the things that i am
proud to leave as a reminder of our time
here is the addition to the white house
permanent collection of paintings
Thomas Sully's portrait of Fanny Kemble
is sheer romance and I love it
this is our most recent acquisition for
the permanent collection Robert hen Rise
gypsy girl the first painting acquired
during our stay at the White House was
Winslow home was surf it proud snack I
saved my favorite the Mary Cassatt for
last you can almost feel the love
between the mother and those children
look at that little girl is she
wondering but the small child is going
to mean to her life it's such a dear
painting it seems to set the tone of the
room it's where the family shared so
many personal and intimate moments where
we felt we were in the heart of the
house really at home
each of the rooms in the family quarters
of the White House has a special
personality a distinctive mood here the
treaty room has a dark green velvety
look its ornate decor reflects the
opulence of the Victorian period right
after the Civil War
this became the Cabinet Room for
President Andrew Johnson but it was
President Grant who introduced this
table with so many succeeding presidents
used to conduct the nation's business
until 19 - that was when the country
outgrew the second floor President
Theodore Roosevelt who had six children
and was not tradition-bound built the
West Wing presidential offices
separating once and for all the family
quarters from the day-to-day work of the
chief executive many objects bring to
mind earlier presidents the torches of
Andrew Jackson this lamp presented to
mrs. Grover Cleveland and this total
Cheryl wastebasket of President Grant
guaranteed to attract the young boys who
visit us the chandelier has an
interesting story behind it it was
designed for the East Room in president
grants time but it soon passed room to
room until it finally wound up gracing
President Theodore Roosevelt's new
office every time the door opened it
tinkled distracting him greatly he
ordered it to be sent to the Capitol and
he was supposed to have said put it in
the vice president's office and it will
keep him awake and there it remained
until my husband became vice president
in 1961 during mrs. Kennedy's renovation
Lyndon was instrumental in returning it
to the White House where it hangs today
this room has seen many treaty signings
in our time
I've witnessed two treaties here
involving the geographic extremes of our
country the first was the capital Bello
treaty which made the summer home of
Franklin Delano Roosevelt an
international park between Canada and
the United States behind this table
Prime Minister Pierson of Canada and my
husband was seated flanked by the
delegations I remember James Roosevelt
and Miss grace Tully the president's
personal secretary it was a thrilling
look back into the past and then from a
northernmost part of the country to the
southernmost in October of 67 the chammy
czar treaty was signed here returning to
Mexico a small strip of land long and
dispute between our countries what a
feeling of goodwill there was that day
the Texas congressman from the border
districts were here and a delegation
from Mexico everyone I felt was saying
to himself it's done at last I can
recall some other writing performed at
this table all that will never go down
in history I was showing my guests the
rooms on the second floor we entered the
treaty room and as I began my recital I
saw on the table some rather tattered
notebooks and chewed pencils a high
school algebra and a Latin book it was
evident that Linda and Lucy had
discovered what I too would soon learn
that this room is mighty conducive to
getting work done almost from the
beginning I've used this room to launch
the projects closest to my heart it's a
good place to gather your committee or
your group talking to being a program
and get it moving
most of our beautification planning was
done right here we took our notes on
president grants table and our liaison
with the outside world was this old
French telephone made back in the 1890s
and
I know that one day when I walked
through the finished lyndon b johnson
library at the university of texas vivid
memories of this room will come to mind
for almost three years our various
library committees have met here
bringing in the Chancellor and Regents
architects historians and archivists and
all manner of design exhibit people here
we have watched the library grow from
just a germ of an idea to a real living
repository of history and so a room that
started out as a working environment by
succession of presidents still provides
that very important function for 20th
century first ladies with a variety of
projects it is a working room but like
any room in the White House it is also a
collection of memories
having the entire family together for
lunch is a Joey but also a rarity
Linden's hours vary with his work and
the girls are just as unpredictable but
once in a while everyone's activity
should coincide and we gather in the
family dining room his cheesy still
think it's almost like a little English
baby lot of hair even angel looks so
much like he's bad his bone on his
kidney I thought it was a tractor with a
bit overweight fun casual handwriting on
and it's not our time
it's adorable but their very name is
that the for gas tank so their hit case
it's do i you know i think that what
about parting gifts white house might be
in residence high chair permanent but
Linda not to give it don't you think
let me keep my good say give them our
Patrick's women in ginger will you be
glad if we get you a high tech so do
your very own high chair for ever
Luci Baines what time would you guys it
was pretty bright color my black wait
for me oh yes ma'am and when I go down
I'll find out how exactly how much to a
penny the young government media other
one was and savagely plating was alright
and I will then give you a check the for
business
hand in half - grandmother hatches and
one grandmother playpen which will take
up residence at the ranch when I can get
a bit out the orders escort agency Rob's
place a place at night here but I bet
we'll have two that will be a night airs
at the same town without and everybody
well I know how many birds is in a high
chairman and will still be in a junior
chair it's not a high chair just tell me
you can take maybe a baton the trade-off
for not being one of my tears but the
nice needed for exceeds last mother you
trying to tell me something good
you want to get your little word in any
way I make you think you going
you watch to go oh god y'all that y'all
know nothing dad in your head
to me the yellow over room is the
loveliest room in all the white house
while our living room is homey and cozy
this room is formal and elegant yet
there is life here it is warm and
inviting it is one room in the white
house their formal ceremony in two
mingles with family life
it symbolizes in a way the role a
president's family plays while living
here but the personal life and the
official duties are always closely
related President Franklin Roosevelt's
bedroom was next door and he would use
this room as a sitting room and an
office for us it has been the main
drawing room and on a winter evening the
fire is a magnet for good conversation
traditionally the yellow oval room has
been used for entertaining and for
receptions in fact this is where the
first official reception ever held at
the White House took place here on a
chilly January first in eighteen and one
John and Abigail Adams receive the
ministers from the first six countries
that had recognized this brand-new
nation and still today this room offers
hospitality the visiting Chiefs of State
this is where we invite the prime
ministers or kings and their wives for
that half hour or so before a state
dinner the earlier part of the day is
filled with honors and formal ceremonies
on the South Lawn colorful fanfare
sometimes a parade this has always been
an impressive experience a
responsibility I go to the third floor
before the occasion and look at the
great map case
and pull down Liberia India when I read
a fairly thick sheaf of briefings on the
visitor and his country I also try to go
over the guest list a good many times
before the state done because hopefully
you can say something more than just how
do you do to our guests who come from
all over the United States to meet the
visiting head of state and then it is a
high moment when the color guard enters
the president scorched the wife of the
visiting chief and I in turn by our
guest for a year perhaps the marine
captain who led the group was Chuck Robb
he was terribly military and impressive
it was not until months that passed that
I realized I might be looking at our
future son-in-law we have had so many
wonderful personal happy times in this
room here Lyndon and I celebrated just
last year our 33rd wedding anniversary
the cake that Linda planned hailed our
time together one third of a century
what a day was our grandson's first
birthday blackall birthdays the climax
is the cake this one provided us with a
household crisis those sticky little
feet and that elegant louis xvi
upholstery in the end the furniture
didn't suck a one-bed but my nerves did
and then that was the Christmas of 67 my
husband was plunged into a trip around
the world prospects were bleak indeed
for our Christmas with the whole family
together I followed his headlines from
Australia to Thailand to Rome and then
gloriously he came home on Christmas Eve
that Christmas we were seven two
sons-in-law and a new baby unspoken was
the thought that next Christmas Chuck
would not be with us
it was a fragile happiness like some
lovely bubble and I think the room must
have sensed it why it was never prettier
it was our first Christmas in the White
House a moment to catch and hold it
seemed to underscore my feeling that
this house is only on loan to its
tenants that we are temporary occupants
linked to a continuity of presidents who
have come before us and who will succeed
us for only a brief time we serve as the
extension of 200 million people holding
their trust working to fulfill it the
man who sits in this chair sits in the
chair that's been occupied by less than
40 men in the long history of this great
Republic he is selected by the will and
by the votes of a majority of the
citizens of this Republic he must
execute the philosophy and the policies
of the people of this nation regardless
of his own personal feelings from time
to time he is the executor of the will
of the people of this nation and he
carriers upon his shoulders day and
night a burden that always seems at
least to him too much to carry
but only for him to carry we'll be
leaving here shortly after having spent
almost 40 years in the Federal service
we came to Washington with some very
deep set convictions we felt that we
could contribute to making this a better
country for all of our people in some
fields we have made great progress
education health housing in some
respects we've had many disappointments
but in the last few years in this house
in this office we have had a chance to
impress upon the people of this nation
those simple convictions that brought us
to this town and that kept me here for
almost four decades it's important to
reflect and look back and see what has
been done because there's no better way
to judge the future than by the past but
the important thing that faces our
country now is for a new president to
look at these new challenges and find
new answers find a means of
communicating with our young and
providing leadership and inspiration for
them so that they will realize that we
do care find a way to help a better
understanding come to our races so that
we can live together in peace and
harmony and equality with justice to all
no president ever came to this office on
a platform of doing what was wrong
most of us have made some decisions that
were wrong and as we leave office in a
good many instances most of the people
seem to feel that most of the things
we've done have been wrong but every man
who's ever occupied this office or sat
at this desk or reclined in this chair
has been dedicated to doing what he
believed was for the best interest of
the people of this country I am utterly
convinced that when any man takes the
oath of office as president he is
determined to do what is right as God
gives him the wisdom to know the right
most people come into the office with
greater dreams and they leave it with
many satisfactions and some
disappointments and always some of their
dreams that have not come true and I am
no exception but I am so grateful and so
proud that I have had my chance and as
to how successfully been doing the
greatest good for the greatest number
the people themselves and their
posterity must ultimately decide I have
the satisfaction my family has the
satisfaction that we gave it all we had
and we think we provided some of the
answers to the needs of our time